ça me dérange le plus plus plus plus
plus déjà sur tout ça c'est au niveau
d'ici
soit vraiment le plus plat et le moins
possible que ce soit vraiment très très
fin et que j'ai le corps qui part en
quoi d'accord et Paris au niveau des
pectoraux bah qui soit défini en fait
bien ici et ici qu'on va dégager la
ceinture ça va retrécir la ceinture et
on va élargir le haut du corps les pecs
et les deltoïdes Robin en est déjà à sa
deuxième liposuccion en seulement trois
ans clairement plus on multiplie les
positions plus le risque d'irrégularité
d'insatisfaction et de complications en
général augmente
très sympathique Robin qui influenceur
on a pu voir dans l'épisode de Zone
Interdite d'hier soir moi je ne juge pas
chacun fait ce qu'il veut s'il a envie
de se faire un chirurgie esthétique il a
fait en tout cas c'est très beau ma mère
je te le dis non mais c'est vrai voilà
après en tout cas c'est vrai tu es beau
absolument est incroyable que moi
alors on y apprend donc que tu as
réalisé plusieurs opérations qui rejet
esthétique qu'est-ce que tu as réalisé
déjà alors en fait moi j'ai fait deux
opérations donc en 2019 j'ai fini
possession et en même temps on avait
fait une bichette tenue parce que
j'avais de la graisse
qu'on a des excès de graisse dans les
joues souvent les présentateurs télé
tout ça ils le font ah oui c'est très
euh ça creuse
j'aime bien c'est vrai que c'est moi ma
chirurgie esthétique j'ai arrêté de
boire
alors sinon donc dernièrement donc en
novembre j'ai fait une liposuccion
donc du ventre ah d'accord du dos et
j'ai fait une gynécomastie bah comme
Benjamin Castaldi
quoi
35 en fait c'est une donc la bichectomie
c'est un excès de graisse qu'on a donc
dans les pectoraux d'accord et donc tu
as vu ça toi alors bah parce que j'avais
des l'impression d'avoir des seins en
fait c'était vraiment très très moche et
les hormones
j'ai plus d'hormones masculines que
féminine comme toi alors quand tu avais
des gros seins tu les as fait enlever
pour les mettre ailleurs
alors et on va y revenir dans quelques
instants parce que c'est vrai que c'est
dû aux hormones et donc c'était beaucoup
critiqué sur Twitter hier sur Twitter ça
a été très très critiqué
les gens ont dit de fait du sport
voilà sur notre opération parce que en
fait c'est un partenariat c'est ça alors
exactement
une opération très lourde et surtout
très onéreuse 25000 €. mais Robin ne
paiera pas ce prix-là il a obtenu une
ristourne de 80%
en signant un contrat commercial avec le
chirurgien ce contrat oblige donc Robin
à parler de son opération durant six
mois auprès de son million d'abonnés sur
les réseaux sociaux je suis avec Docteur
Matt alors docteur math comment ça va ça
va très bientôt Robin ça va super
bienvenue à Dubaï merci beaucoup alors
c'est officiel je vous l'annonce demain
docteur Malte va m'opérer pour demain je
suis prêt donc passe une bonne soirée à
jeun à minuit et on se voit demain à 7h
ok merci beaucoup salut Robin ciao les
deux partenariat c'est quoi tu postes
une vidéo et tout gratuit tu enlèves
toute la Grèce si tu enlèves les yoxs
tout particulièrement il a traité ma
mère
il est vraiment super comme médecin par
contre il y a eu des propos vraiment
polémiques Zone Interdite a tenu
d'ailleurs moi je me suis arnaquer par
zone interdite complètement pourquoi ils
t'ont dit quoi ton interdite alors bah
déjà me concernant avant
avant tout moi il m'avait démarché en
fait parce que tout je suis comédien en
même temps de ça je suis chef
d'entreprise et en même temps je suis
influenceur sur les réseaux sociaux et
voilà c'est ça et donc il m'avait
démarcher en disant écoute Robin à ton
âge à seulement 20 ans tu as fait
beaucoup de choses on aimerait bien en
apprendre plus sur ta vie tout ça voilà
donc
ici ils sont venus avec un partenariat
pardon cette boutique de quoi toi alors
moi je vends des Kiki et des Schneck
alors c'est des gaufres en forme de
Kikine minou comme comme
ce soir
rien à voir avec ceux d'avant
il devait venir ils sont venus
d'ailleurs me filmer en train de faire
des kiki voilà toujours dit de faire sa
passion son métier donc je l'ai fait
donc c'est quoi ta passion de la vie
alors normalement c'est le cinéma moi
c'est les Kiki et c'est normal
malheureusement
c'est des kiki le bateau malheureusement
j'ai le mal de mer
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ce qu'il fait là au chocolat
c'est très bon le bonheur de le voir va
devoirs c'est mignon bon allez encore
meilleur que beau alors du coup donc ils
sont venus ils ont fait vraiment des
choses super on a été dans une
parfumerie de luxe ou la parfumerie
offert pour 1500 euros de parfum un
parfum en caméraman un parfum
journaliste un parfum à moi-même ils ont
rien mis tout ça et après quand j'ai
appris le titre donc moi c'était
normalement c'était sur les influenceurs
sur ma vie sur mon métier sur ce que
j'ai galéré tout ça voilà ça fait quand
même de 15 ans depuis que j'ai 15 ans je
fais des figurations voilà je suis
intermittent du spectacle depuis 5 ans
tous des choses à pouvoir dire aux
jeunes et leur donner de la force mais
en fait pas du tout en fait je me suis
retrouvé dans une émission déjà le nom
scandale des dérives chercher
quand tu lui as montré ton opération
elle a tout de suite validé regarde
Robin qui a subi une liposuccion du
torse entier va montrer pour la première
fois à sa mère son corps tout neuf alors
a-t-il le corps d'apollon dont il rêvait
[Musique]
voilà la surprise
3 2 1 vas-y ouvre les yeux ah ouais
ah ouais incroyable
il y a pas de marque il y a rien il y a
pas de
il faut reconnaître qu'il y a une
différence on me dit je t'offre
pour refaire les fesses le ventre les
salles à l'intérieur des cuisses des
sous-bras les paupières et les joues je
parle direct ah je le fais
tout là alors tu as vu ça
c'est bien
non non en gros au contraire donc moi
c'est totalement naturel parce que moi
ils m'ont pris ma graisse ils ont trié
la graisse la mauvaise et la bonne ils
m'ont remis la bonne ils m'ont mis 500
grammes dans chaque pectoraux
on délocalise exactement la Grèce et de
la glace dans chaque pectoraux de 500
vous voulez voir
[Rires]
pudique qu'on voit là-dedans alors du
coup voilà tu es content tu es content
ou pas je suis très content de ce café
docteur maths c'est vraiment super par
contre donc dans l'émission donc voilà
ça fait c'était quoi tu as fait
anesthésie générale anesthésie générale
tu t'es couché comme ça tu t'es réveillé
comme ça exact exactement tu es content
que liposuccion c'était pas fait un
œdème alors en fait ce qui est bien
c'est que docteur maths lui peut-être ça
super bien j'ai eu aucun bleu concerne
contrairement à mon opération en 2000
non non
on dit quand c'est mal on met toujours
le point ouais c'est mauvais nanani par
contre on sait bien donc quand c'est
bien on le dit pas hier je suis passé
dans cette émission catastrophique on a
dit des choses alors on a su bien dire
on m'a fait passer pour un influenceur
de Dubaï hyper superficielle qui s'est
fait refaire il y a quoi dedans dans
l'opération et on l'a pas dit la
circoncision non bien sûr quand j'avais
8 ans parce qu'on m'a demandé combien
j'en ai fait et les amygdales
pourquoi tu t'es fait circoncer à 8 ans
bah parce que c'est parce que c'est pour
des questions et mes parents voulaient
faire et donc ça dure voilà non mais du
coup quand on m'a posé les questions je
l'ai j'ai dit les noms d'opérations donc
après on dirait il s'est fait refaire
quatre fois bah oui monsieur s'est fait
refaire quatre fois et on prend on vient
de critiquer on vient me [ __ ] dans une
émission scandale avec des gens qui
payent 5 euros l'injection qui vont se
faire dans des trucs complètement pourri
alors que moi je vais dans des endroits
comme les chevaux c'est des vrais des
cheveux les cheveux
[Rires]
on a pu suivre le parcours de Luna et de
son opération du nez c'est une jeune
fille de 16 ans et ses parents du faire
un prêt pour payer l'opération de leur
fille regarde
depuis 2 ans l'adolescente nourrit un
terrible complexe je ressens un peu de
honte d'avoir un peu ce nez là j'aime
pas la bosse là alors Pascal et Cathy
ont accepté qu'à seulement 16 ans leur
fille subissent une opération de
chirurgie esthétique cette décision est
lourde de responsabilité et elle a
également un coup 5200 euros pour les
financer ils n'ont eu d'autres choix que
de faire un emprunt à la banque ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va aller enfoncer
la bosse ensuite on va remonter
la pointe et on va réduire les narines
même si les parents sont là et
d'ailleurs ici une des papiers ils sont
responsables mais pour moi 16 ans là ça
me gêne je trouve que la chirurgie
esthétique ça devrait à partir de 18 ans
voilà les gens décident seul les parents
sont d'accord excuse-moi tu peux décider
mais là là je suis désolé à l'école si
elle ça se passait
psychologique antérieur notre rame de sa
vie elle le vit super mal elle garde le
masque même quand elle a pas besoin du
corps du masque
pour changer de sexe à 10 ans je pense
que là tu peux être d'accord pour
changer son pif à 16 ans
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous saviez il y a un truc de
fou si vous nous rejoignez à 20h44 on
est en direct c'est que maintenant on
peut faire changer sa couleur Dieu
définitivement définitivement ça veut
dire demain voilà tu te tais tu veux
choisir c'est chéri n'a fait elle a
économisé 7500 euros pour pouvoir se
payer cette opération et avoir les yeux
verts dont elle a toujours rêvé alors il
y a un petit risque qui vous dise il y a
un tout petit risque d'être aveugle et
c'est réversible
l'opération qu'elle va subir a été
réalisée pour la première fois en France
il y a seulement 10 ans le chirurgien
qui va l'opérer lui rappelle les risques
encourus lors de l'intervention
bien que ce c'est un silence soit très
très rare et n'est pas zéro elle va
subir une kératop pigmentation autrement
dit une sorte de tatouage de la cornée
l'intervention a lieu sous anesthésie
locale elle se déroule en deux temps
d'abord découpez la cornée au laser pour
créer un petit tunnel la couleur a été
fabriquée sur mesure pour correspondre
au vers souhaité par sherine le
chirurgien l’injecte dans la cornée de
la jeune femme en moins d'une heure
l'opération est terminée
[Musique]
vas-y alors vas-y les yeux bleus quand
quelqu'un les yeux très très bleu et
magnifique tu le regardes tu peu importe
le visage tu es focus sur le regard
quand quelqu'un a un beau regard des
yeux bleus c'est magnifiquement ils sont
verts tu crois on va dire des banalités
comme ça à 20h45 qu'est-ce que sont fous
là ok Cyril moi je suis la reine de la
chirurgie parce que même si je veux dire
pourquoi parce qu'en fait je sollicite
j'avais de la vie c'est un contouring de
ouf 3h au maquillage
tu as pas fait les poitrine mais non
j'ai des hormones
je reçois des millions de messages par
les chirurgiens français anglais
américain et ils me disent on voudrait
vous faire quelque chose alors j'aurais
attendez que j'ai un enfant ou deux
j'aimerais pas le faire alors je veux
dire quelque chose pour lever parce que
Cyril me met à la menthe chaque minute
j'aimerais me lever pour expliquer les
gens qui ont envie de faire de la les
gens qui ont envie de faire de la
chirurgie esthétique parce qu'ils ont
une bonne sur le nez ou parce que ils
ont un problème de Menton et qu'ils ont
pas de ça ils ont pas de cul et que ça
leur rend la vie plus heureuse je leur
dis allez-y mais il faut pas que ça
vienne dangereux parce que de se changer
l'oeil avec la rétine ou tu peux devenir
aveugle il y a des circonstances très
atténuantes et là je dis attention la
chirurgie mais quand vous avez envie de
vous sentir bien
[Rires]
et là tu sors
[Applaudissements]
il y a plusieurs facteurs qui expliquent
le développement de la chirurgie
esthétique chez les jeunes parmi eux les
filtres sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
des gens qui veulent devenir comme les
filtres Inès à la 27 ans elle montre
même une photo d'elle avec un filtre à
son chirurgien regardez
dès qu'elle se filme ou se prend en
photo elle utilise une application qui
retouche son visage cette beauté
virtuelle Inès fait tout pour
l'atteindre dans la vraie vie et pour
cela elle a recours à un autre
subterfuge est-ce que le résultat au
niveau du nez est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir ça ou pas
donc ça c'est une vidéo de vous oui avec
un filtre donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
une beauté virtuelle c'est pas la
réalité de ce qu'on représente nous-même
et Inès elle réalise régulièrement des
injections l'acide hyaluronique sur
résorbe elle doit donc recommencer en
fait tous les ans quoi ça coûte cette
cette histoire on sait pas non personne
entre 300 400 500 ça dépend des
practiciens mais après quand les gens
font des choses non non moi j'ai que 21
ans j'ai pas besoin de faire beau
magnifique
pour la vitamine
de fond de teint c'est pas grave moi je
me maquille pas comme ça
l'agression une simple seringue remplie
d'acide hyaluronique suffit l'acide
hyaluronique est une substance déjà
présente dans notre peau et qui possède
un très fort pouvoir hydratant
l'intervention ne dure que quelques
minutes et le résultat est immédiat mais
comme l'acide hyaluronique se résorbe
avec le temps les faits n'est pas
permanent si elle veut conserver son
nouveau-né Inès devra refaire des
injections tous les ans
qu'est-ce que j'ai entendu là le nez
c'est vrai que c'est le c'est la forme
du visage parce que tu as dit
[Rires]
alors il y a aussi des personnes qui se
font des injections sauvages oui voilà
et ça c'est une guéris puisque ces
dernières sont pas des professionnels et
sous la cela engendre souvent des
catastrophes vous avez déjà fait des
injections sauvages alors non justement
en premier lieu j'aimerais expliquer une
situation
sauvages à New York ont perdu les gens
mais les bras parce qu'il y a eu en fait
une infection comme ça il y a un an la
jeune femme décide de faire appel à un
cabinet clandestin pour payer moins cher
ces injections tout se passe bien
jusqu'au jour où elle déclare une grave
infection elle se rend alors en urgence
chez un médecin
doublé de volume et les douleurs elles
sont de plus en plus fortes et la nuit
bah ça a pété il y a énormément de pitié
quand le docteur pulchini la reçoit la
lèvre supérieure de Sarah est attaquée
par une bactérie extrêmement dangereuse
sarah a sans doute été contaminée en
raison d'un problème d'hygiène les
conséquences auraient pu être
dramatiques Sarah s'est promis
dorénavant de toujours passer par un
médecin pour réaliser ses injections
mais parfois il est impossible de savoir
à qui on a réellement à faire
tu as des belles dents aussi la même
chose que toi tu as fait quoi des
facettes j'ai pas fait aucune facette
toi mon frère
c'est pour ça on a vu l'extrait là que
beaucoup de jeunes notamment vont dans
des cabinets clandestins pour faire des
injections sauvages parce que ça coûte
180 euros à la place de 280 ou 300 donc
les tarifs sont tellement bas que c'est
en temps mais c'est hyper dangereux
alors il y a Chloé qui a voulu se
refaire les fesses aussi la tendance
c'est des fesses bombées voilà elles se
sentait complexées voilà regardez elle a
fait les fesses bombées voilà bah
regardez moi je que vous toi tu as pas
fait ça toi
vas-y c'est parti tu l'aimes bien pour
augmenter le volume d'un fessier il
existe deux techniques les implants ou
l'injection de graisse plus souvent
appelée BBL pour brasilienne backlift
l'opération consiste à lui prélever la
graisse du ventre et des cuisses pour
lui réinjecter dans chaque fesse
pourtant elle comporte un gros risque
celui de faire une embolie graisseuse en
clair que la graisse réinjectée Vienne
boucher les veines l'opération se fait
sous anesthésie générale une fois la
graisse du ventre et des cuisses
aspirées près de 400 seringues en tout
celle-ci est purifiée une centaine de
seringues et près de 4 heures sont
nécessaires pour son nouveau fessier il
vaut mieux que la forme lui plaise car
cette intervention coûte 7000 euros
alors pour l'instant elle est plutôt
fière du résultat vous voulez voir le
résultat tout ça
tu as fait un mois que Chloé s'est fait
opérer des fesses je commence à avoir
vraiment les résultats enfin et je me
dis que ça ne sera que mieux même dans
un à deux mois alors
tes commandes
pour conserver sa nouvelle silhouette et
ses fesses rebondir Chloé doit
maintenant avoir une hygiène de vie
irréprochable
personne
toi tu toi tu es content lors de ton
résultat tu le conseillerais à des gens
moi j'avais quand même une annonce à
faire parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
dit dans un interdite pas encore parlé
du docteur je ramène un papier c'est
quoi
c'est une ordonnance qui dit qu'en fait
je dois faire un test d'hormones parce
qu'il s'avère que j'ai une tumeur
bénigne à l'hypophyse qui fait que j'ai
trop d'oestrogènes et qui a créé ma
gynéco mastie le fait que j'ai pas de
poils et le fait que j'ai une voix aiguë
et peut-être ma sexualité qui fait
peut-être que je suis bi voilà tu as pas
une voix hyper aiguë
et du coup voilà dans un interdite
pourtant j'en avais parlé mais ça ils
l'ont pas dit voilà comme ça voilà donc
quand j'ai tous les gens qui me
critiquent sur Twitter va au sport
nanani nanana bah vas-y bah d'abord va
chez un docteur pour ton problème
d'hormones
aujourd'hui
si tu as envie de te faire ça tu fais ça
chacun fait ce qu'il veut les gars elle
a les donneurs de leçon j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] on est obligé est-ce que tu es
bien toi est-ce que tu es content si tu
es content je suis très content voilà tu
es content c'est l'essentiel
quand tu vois ça quand même pas envie de
dire que c'est un truc dans son gâté
réparatrice moi je veux bien
et moi pourquoi les gens réparatrice
gynéco
je pense que la la jeune fille qui a 16
ans qui refait son nez ok d'accord elle
a des complexes parce que
psychologiquement ça peut être compliqué
mais quand je vois la nana la Kalash et
7000 € alors qu'elle était bien avant et
qu'elle a 7000 € juste pour avoir des
FFF un petit peu plus mignonne
il y a des gens qui vont jouer avec
leurs yeux quand même pour changer de
couleur de dans les yeux pour ils
peuvent être aveugle moi
c'est de la débilitation responsabilité
c'est qu'ils ont de l'argent à [ __ ] en
l'air ils veulent balancer de l'argent
il y a pas que ça il y a des gens qui
ont beaucoup économiser
le PEL bien sûr que les gens ils ont dit
fais du sport
en fait du sport vous si vous avez envie
de faire en disant oui mais regardez
maintenant je suis malade regarde
vue des émissions où il y a de pleurer
après regarder
une maladie qui faisait que il avait des
excédents parce que moi de base quand
j'ai fait l'émission faut pas me dire
après oui bah il fallait s'y attendre
parce que moi quand ils sont juste et
pour présenter mon métier vous savez
quand on a des factures d'électricité à
payer tous les jours des gérer les
employés à seulement 20 ans c'est quand
même quelque chose je voulais montrer ça
moi de base et la femme m'a montré dans
une table pour me faire passer pour
quelqu'un que je suis pas et en plus
quelqu'un que je suis pas et même pas
parler de mon problème d'hormones voilà
donc à la fin on se passe dans les
scandales des dérives des machins de ça
toi j'en ai marre voilà calme-toi je
casse tout calme-toi et pas mal il est
pas mal hein
regardez vous avez pas l'ordonnance qui
vient de nous dire
ils font la photo sur Instagram mais
s'il a envie il fait ce qu'il veut c'est
sa vie les mecs arrêtez de vous mêler de
la vie des autres